go turn off the door t'wall turn off the
door
that's something you set off camera that
I'm now gonna reference like a douchebag
oh man people hate us so much on the
Internet
man I can't believe these annoying
teenagers what a book you
I can fill man or maybe I maybe I I can
film and play at the same time you only
need one hand to play yeah it's like
Bayonetta they have a one handed mode so
you could play the game put bang around
you kids you keep saying you know like
speak loud so they can hear you talk
loud so that the camera can hear you
mumbler yeah then they can make fun of
you better are these the same people
that made the creaky roll thirty-fourth
they make the rule 34 stuff yes it's the
same guys
my arm is getting so tired from holding
up the camera hey why don't you get some
recording equipment you cheap bastard
seventy-eight percent no it's because
I'm panicking I'm checking the lights
every 10 seconds well you sons of sons
of anarchy
does anyone else sad that the Fifty
Shades of Grey movie actually using your
fun of me actually it's been out for
like several years how do meio date has
been up for like ten years penny what
are you gonna make up a so annoying
Xavier never Thomas he should be here
just cussing and ruining people's chairs
yeah like he loves to do
oh god my arm is gonna fall off will you
hold the camera yeah that's why I
thought I'll put the camera down and
let's see how this goes
they just treat it like a
they six the second I stopped filming
something something happens and I died
and yeah you press the red button on the
camera all oh it's your turn now you
bastard all right
why are you so contempt on not filming
them
are you worried your I'll be doing most
the effort you don't have to do anything
you just got to sit there and talk talk
okay this game came out on Steam today I
think I voted for it to be on the green
light because I wanted to play it and
now here it is and and I'm terrible at
it
if you put a picture of boobs in the
thumbnail of the video and you watch it
you guarantee also you need to angle
yourself so I can see your friggin face
okay your friggin dumb face yeah I don't
know I turn on the second flashlight
hang on Freddy Eddie Eddie Eddie night
for a single guy I think it's made by a
group of people sure I'm sure
don't look directly into the flashlights
yeah I know
ones really bright eyes he's already on
the move what why are the cameras just
glitching out they're looking on what
all of the cameras are gone all of the
cameras are gone
yeah oh my god already hello
alright yeah pretty good Fox he's being
a pain
you know like it speak louder yes do it
I hate this game it's so good Sears they
could outrun usain bolt I don't know who
that is
crash ah he'll save every one of us ah
that sucks moves I'm going to kill you
it might be it yeah
incidentally they needed Jenner you
don't say like their names
no they happening hey that names like
this dog is chica Freddy's Freddy Fox
he's actually named foxy I don't know
what the planes actually I just imagined
bonnie bonnie i think it's fun I think
it's cherub Bono
I think the bunny is named Bonnie Chaz
Bono okay you're all I don't like you
please please leave me alone please
oh stop it I don't like you
I'm gonna power so fast I like this game
okay
oh I think these moments the most funny
that awkward moment where you don't know
where the robot is that should be a meme
no ah you see how fast you oh look at
that piece of crap
he's the flash
he's the flash well he runs up at you
and then eats your face ok so there's
like rumors that that's the one that ate
a small child's frontal lobe Xavier do
you see this what Oh
close the door they're already closed
that's why ha okay they're close they
are not okay
keep it closed
they are never opening yes never open
anything ever oh okay yeah we're good
now
good enough what no oh good I said no
okay no wait later
here lies a broken young man now
killed by a duck yes where'd it go
Jax Minh this is painted on the wall
this is there forever I have to take the
wall with me if I ever move out which
sucks cuz it's in the middle and there
might be like a stud behind it so it's
just gonna break off and into separate
plates of the drywall I'm just gonna
hang myself on that fan yep there we go
all right Jackson's in the bathroom
changing his clothes he pooed his panty
see it's up to me now
we're good news all the lights are off
now that's not good news you lied Oh
foxy as long as he's just barely peeking
out it's okay and I guess I was actually
glad that was chica which is a chicken
or a duck well if it's called chica
that's probably a chicken is Spanish for
girl might gee Jax and I didn't know
that thank you for informing me have you
made it through a single night or have I
done it I'm practically carrying this
duo your carry every time I turn off the
camera I get scared because I feel like
they're just gonna be there waiting for
me I feel like every time they turn off
all the cameras it's always me when I am
feel like I've been playing for 15
minutes us
it was me Austin it was me all along
yep okay I'm closing the doors and we're
done we're done yep okay close the doors
close both of the doors oh he's out on
the prowl come on only two I think the
date that time that was last longer and
we have less power need to both of those
I mean barely under 50% I can't keep
this up you're the one who asked me to
get this game he asked me to get this
game four days like he started asking me
last Sunday it's Friday now every day
he's like man you gotta get that game
we'll play it on Friday when I come over
I'm like yeah that'll be great man and
then and then we start playing it and
we're both regretting it it's terrifying
like I haven't legitimately screamed at
a jump-scare in a long time the pee
mattress yeah yep fill me don't don't
shake the camera don't cover my shot
I blame you for this tilted sideways all
right you now then now different
perspectives gonna be all messed up
unless I fix it net innate that fix it a
minute that's your forte I guess that's
your thing
remember that car video I kind of liked
it more
where we drove around on a cart plus
terrifying fall for the legendary Kato
scoreboard in the ghetto scoreboard
which has already been in this video has
it yeah
another video about the ghetto
scoreboard maybe maybe you should be
like a recurring thing like it's in
every single video yeah everything a
woman this is gonna be just have a beer
it's more porn and just me going
Spanish the Spanish it's like super sis
I can bet in soccer when when they have
to like stretch out the screaming of
goal because they don't know who got the
goal so they have to check their name so
that's why they stretch it out
also you spending your pains watching
this ology stalling at all one of you if
even then there's gonna be five people
that watch this video and three of them
will dislike the video